احتجاجات واسعة في انحاء البلاد
سقط خلالها مئات المصابين من
اباد عن رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان بعد حكمها بعدم
للدول الاخرى من تطبيع العلاقات
مع الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد حسب
المحتجين وقوات الامن. الف صاروخ
فلسطيني تجعل القبة الحديدية
قانونية قرار اعتقاله وكان
اعتقال خان ادى الى موجة
اكدت الصين ان خطط حلف شمال
الاطلسي الناتو لفتح مكتب له في
تكنولوجية فعن اي جهوزية يتحدث
وصواريخ غزة تتبختر في اجواء تل
ابيب لتدخل حركة حماس على خط هذه
المواجهات وذلك بعد ان ابلغ
الخميس بيع مروحيات من طراز
شينوك بقيمة مليارات ونصف
اليابان على استخلاص الدروس من
التاريخ وان تبقى ملتزمة بمسار
التنف العسكرية الامريكية في
سوريا خلال شهر واحد. الرشق
لا تظهر الخسائر الاسرائيلية
انما الخسارة الحقيقة هي خسارة
الهادئ. وقال المتحدث باسم وزارة
الخارجية الصينية في مؤتمر نحث
خلافاتها مع الصين بشأن تايوان
الى نزاع مع بكين. ومن جانب اخر
وموسكو مع وجود عربي للقاهرة.
حيث تجاهلت مصر عدة طلبات
فهل هناك ما تخبئه حماس للكيان
الاسرائيلي? احداث والتطورات.
اعلن قائد نظام بطارية القبة
الحديدية الاسرائيلية المضادة
السعودي فيصل بن فرحان ان
الاتفاق الذي وقع في جدة بين
التنمية السلمية وتجنب القيام
باشياء من شأنها ان تزعزع الثقة
وتؤثر على السلام والاستقرار في
هذه المنطقة. قال وزير الخارجية
اليابان تثير قلق كبيرا للمجتمع
الدولي وخاصة دول اسيا والمحيط
اسقاط صاروخ فلسطيني ببضعة الاف
الدولارات فوق منطقة تل ابيب
الصواريخ الفلسطينية المطلقة على
المستوطنات والمدن المحتلة منذ
صاروخية كثيفة تجاه غلاف القبة
الحديدية للكيان ليصل عدد
لتهدئة مع الجهاد الاسلامي فان
حماس ستدخل بالمواجهات بشكل علني
الكبرى وهذا باختصار هو حال
الكيان بعد الرد الغزاوي. بينما
وبولندا. وذلك بسبب القرار
الاخير لبولندا والتي اقترحت
بداية هجمات الاحتلال على غزة
نحو اكثر من الف صاروخ. ولكن هنا
رفع يديه مستسلما لطائرة مسيرة
اوكرانية. ليقوم مركز التحكم
نعم. هذه المدينة التي قد يشعل
اسمها معركة عسكرية بين روسيا
المليار دولار الى المانيا.
افرجت المحكمة العليا في اسلام
ما افاد موقع. اجازت ادارة
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يوم
ونظام راداراتها في خبرك فكيف
سينتهي هذا التصعيد بين غزة وتل
صحيفة يد عود احرنوت
الاسرائيلية. ليسفر القصف
خطوات واضاف ان الاهم هو
الالتزام بما تم الاتفاق عليه.
الى تعزيز قدرة الحكومة
الامريكية على فرض عقوبات كتحذير
الصاروخية لا تتوقف. غارات
وهجمات اسرائيلية مكثفة على غزة
الجوية في القيادة المركزية
للقوات المسلحة الامريكية سينتقم
تجهز مجموعة من اعضاء الكونجرس
الامريكي مشروع قانون جديد يهدف
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع ياتي كخطوة اولى ستتبعها
الاستراتيجية في سوريا وذلك
صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال
ولكن المقاومة الفلسطينية لم
تسكت وباشرت باطلاق رشقات
فلسطينيا بينهم ستة اطفال وثلاث
نساء وستة من قادة سرايا القدس.
الاسرائيلي على القطاع منذ فجر
الثلاثاء عن مقتل ثلاثة وثلاثين
العديد من ساحات الحرب سابقا
لتشارك في الحرب الاوكرانية وذلك
شيء يطبخ على نار هادئة. ومن
جانب اخر وبسبب نقص لدى روسيا
اعلنت مسؤولة امريكية ان
الولايات المتحدة تسعى لمنع تحول
يقابلها وابل من الرشقات
الصاروخية من المقاومة
للصواريخ انهم جاهزون لجميع
السيناريوهات من وجهة نظر
الوسيط المصري تل ابيب انه اذا
انتهى اليوم وغدا ولم يتم التوصل
اكثر من مليون دولار مع كل صاروخ
يطلق من مقلاع داوود من اجل
الفلسطينية لتعلن بلدية بيت شيمش
قرب القدس عن فتح الملاجئ بحسب
قد قال الطائرات الروسية تحلق
باستمرار فوق رؤوسنا. مشيرا الى
الامريكية بينما كان الجنرال
اللكزس جرينتيفيتش قائد القوات
ان طائرات موسكو نفذت ما لا يقل
عن خمسة وعشرين تحليقا فوق قاعدة
من الكرملين ووصفه بالعمل
العدائي. فهل نشهد حربا جديدة
بين روسيا وبولندا? وفي جبهة
اخرى طرفها هذه المرة واشنطن
بهدف قطع الطريق الوحيد المتبقي
امام موسكو الى قواعدها
لاجراء مناقشات تهدف الى ايجاد
حل سياسي للازمة الاوكرانية. فهل
الحرب الاوكرانية الروسية بين
القوتين مع كر وفر للطرفين. هنا
ينجح اصحاب الضيقة بما فشل به
العالم. لننتقل الى جبهة اخرى من
منطقة دونيتسك شرق اوكرانيا كان
كل هذه الانباء المتضاربة هناك
ونقض المعاهدات في مجال
الاستقرار الاستراتيجي هي اساليب
وتقتربون انتم? ليأتي هنا الدور
للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين.
مؤسس فاجنر الروسية جنود الجيش
الروسي بالفرار من مواقعهم في
لهوي سيبدأ جولة تشمل اوكرانيا
وروسيا وعددا من الدول الاوروبية
امريكية لاغلاق مجالها الجوي
امام الرحلات العسكرية الروسية
تغيير اسم المدينة في الافلام
الوثائقية الى اسمه القديم في
وفق التقارير الغربية. لكن البعض
يتحدثون عن ان هذه الدبابات هي
لاستخدام الدبابات السوفيتية
القديمة التي اثبتت جدارتها في
ويهددون لا للاقتراب من موسكو
لكن مجلة نيوز ويك الامريكية
العقوبات كما يتنفسون. يعاقبون
كل اقترب من روسيا يضغطون يحذرون
وتعلن الطوارئ القصوى. حركة حماس
تدخل خط المواجهة وتشعل الحرب ضد
الجبهات الروسية. هنا تأخذنا
خريطة الاحداث الى كالينجراد
الحقبة السوفيتية. حيث كان اسمها
كونيكس بيرج ليواجه هذا القرار
السلام. حيث اعلنت الصين ان
مبعوثها الخاص لشؤون اوراسيا
في العالم تأسيره طائرة بدون
طيار. ومن ضجة الحرب الى سبل
باخموت ليباشر ويعرض الاستسلام
فجأة للقوات الاوكرانية. نعم لقد
والتي تواجه الجيش الاوكراني
باسلحتها المتقدمة. عادت موسكو
بالمسيرة تقتاده بالفعل الى
موقعهم ليتم اسره ليصبح اول اسير
استخدام العقوبات غير المشروعة
وتجاهل مبدأ المساواة بين الدول
افادت بتحقيق القوات الاوكرانية
اختراقات الخطوط الدفاعية بمدينة
ظهر جندي روسي انتهت ذخيرته
اثناء القتال في محيط مدينة
فقط مجرد روسي لاستدراج القوات
الاوكرانية. وبينما تدور رحى
روسيا فان واشنطن تواصل التجارة
مع موسكو عبر شراء الوقود النووي
القيادة الجوية الامريكية. حول
حول. هل تسمعني? حول. الطائرات
تفجر المفاجأة بقولها انه على
الرغم من العقوبات العديدة ضد
العقوبات على موسكو لتصرخ اوروبا
هي تفرض ولا تنفذ. فما الذي يجري
ونحو الف صاروخ فلسطيني تتجه نحو
الكيان وتل ابيب تفتح الملاجئ
مصر تتجاهل الولايات المتحدة
والسبب روسيا. وواشنطن تفرض
اوكرانيا. وما ان اعلنت كييف
تحقيق هذا الاختراق حتى اتهم
باخموت. لتنفي روسيا حدوث تلك
الاختراقات في مراكز القتال شرق
باخموت. حيث اكد الجيش الاوكراني
استعادة نحو كيلومترين في محيط
المعارك والاشتباكات على الارض
الاوكراني. وبعد التقارير التي
تلحق اضرارا بنظام القانون
الدولي. ومن حرب العقوبات الى
والذي اكد في خطاب القاه
بالنيابة عنه وزير روسي ان
منها بنحو مليار دولار. اتطلبون
من الدول الابتعاد عن روسيا
الاحتلال وبكين تذكر اليابان
بدرس هيروشيما بينما امريكا تتجه
برلين وواشنطن. واشنطن تكسر
عقوبات اوروبا. الامريكان يفرضون
لمعاقبة الدول العربية بسبب
سوريا وصفقة عسكرية مليارية بين
الروسية تحلق فوق رؤوسنا. ما
الذي يحدث يا سادة? بينما هنا
ابيب?